let's be truthful about it because the
holocaust isn't about race
it's about man's inhumanity to man
whoopi goldberg is apologizing for those
controversial comments she made on
monday's the view it all started when
the panel was discussing a tennessee
school district's decision to ban the
graphic novel mouse which is about the
holocaust personally i'm shocked because
you know
given the story of mouse i'm i'm
surprised that that's what
that's what made you uncomfortable the
fact that there was some nudity and uh
i mean it's it's about the holocaust the
killing of six million people but that
didn't that didn't bother you but the
the naked i'm not sure that they don't
use the naked part as a kind of a canard
to throw you off from
the fact that they might like history
that makes white maybe they look bad
but as whoopi continues debating the
topic some of her co-hosts don't agree
let's be truthful about it because the
holocaust isn't about race
no
no it's not about racism
it's about a different race but it's
it's not about race
it's not about race
because
it's about man's inhumanity to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy the oscar winner
immediately received backlash on social
media leading her to apologize on
twitter monday evening whoopi writes
quote on today's show i said the
holocaust is not about race but about a
man's inhumanity to man i should have
said it is about both as jonathan
greenblatt from the anti-defamation
league shared the holocaust was about
the nazis systematic annihilation of the
jewish people who they deemed to be an
inferior race i stand corrected
the actress adds that jewish people
around the world have always had her
support and that will never change quote
i'm sorry for the hurt i have caused
people got very very very angry and
still are angry i mean i'm getting
you know all of the
the mail from folks and
the very real anger because people feel
very differently ahead of her apology
whoopi appeared on the late show with
stephen colbert where she discussed why
she made those comments on the view i
thought we were having
a discussion
because i've i feel
being black when we talk about race it's
a very different thing to me i respect
everything everyone is saying to me and
i
you know i don't want to fake apologize
you know i i was i very upset about that
people are
misunderstood what i was saying and when
e.t spoke to the egot winner ahead of
the views 25th season she said this
about the panelists having different
opinions
we're doing what we're supposed to be
doing this is our this is our gig and
this is you know
our our uh
our gift from
the world because not everybody gets to
have an opinion not everybody gets to
say this is what i think and here's why
and let's talk about this this is a
really great job it's a really great job
and i'm going to speak for us but i
think we're lucky is
hell